It isn't that the only that,
because if you're healthy and energetic,
you're much more likely to be successful
because it's very hard to be successful
if you're ill obviously.
I mean so because the competition is
just too high.
And both,
both genders,
both sexes select each other for
attractiveness,
both select for intelligence,
both at select for personality,
although the different,
there are differences there in terms of
what's what stressed.
But so,
so,
so I think you can derive a couple of
things out of out of this.
And this is where I think people are
different than,
than other animals.
Importantly different is that,
so you imagine that there's tremendous
selection pressure to,
uh,
towards the production,
let's say of men who are good at
climbing male dominance hierarchies or
are climbing the male dominance
hierarchy.
But the thing that's so interesting
about people is that we've multiplied
our dominance hierarchies.
You know,
if you take an animal that's got a
rather static behavioral pattern,
then there's,
there's a single hierarchy.
Elephant seals are a good example of
that.
So elephant seals,
the males are absolutely massive.
They're way,
way bigger than the females.
And they basically have harems roughly
speaking,
and they use physical prowess as their
marker of status essentially.
And obviously size is a huge part of
that because otherwise the male elephant
seals wouldn't be as,
they're massive.
These things are absolutely enormous.
And so it's just power slash health,
you know,
maybe aggression,
something like that.
It's whatever makes them more um,
suitable for the kind of physical combat
that elephant seals engage it.
So,
and the degree to which power is
associated with dominance status in
those sorts of situations seems to be
associated with the size differential
between males and females.
So the more power is an issue with
regards to male competence,
the larger the bales are compared to the
females and the more likely the males
are going to have a harem relationship
with the females.
And you see that a little bit in human
beings because men are bigger than
women.
They're not overwhelmingly bigger.
That's sexual dimorphism.
And you know,
there's some men that are smaller than
some women,
but on average men are tolerant there.
They have more upper body strength and
so forth.
So there is a power element to male
competition,
but it's not as extended as it would be
among animals.
Say like,
like elephant seals.
So in the elephant seal you see maybe
there's one stable set of traits that's
being selected for that makes the males
more likely to reproduce.
But human beings,
we're very weird creatures because we're
so conceptually flexible.
And so what seems to have happened,
maybe we started males started selecting
each other for don in dominance
competitions for something like
cognitive flexibility and
conscientiousness.
It's something like that.
So that would be the ability to
abstractly represent the world and then
the ability to operate effectively
within it,
to represent yourself socially in a way.
And then to carry through with that
because that enables people to trust
you.
So it's something like,
and so that produced cortical expansion
and then women were selecting men who
are good at that,
in that produce cortical expansion.
And then there's an arms race between
women and men with regards to
intelligence.
So the women kept up or they certainly
kept up with,
with,
with intelligence as,
as the evolutionary cycle continued.
But one of the consequences of selection
for cortical expansion and increased
cognitive flexibility was that the
number of dominance hierarchies that
human beings could produce started to
multiply,
right?
Because there's all sorts of ways that
you can be successful.
There's you think about how many ways
you can be successful in a modern
culture and and you can be successful in
dimensions that aren't really even
associated with each other.
So you can be successful socially that
that's what an extrovert would do.
You could be successful in terms of
intimate relationships.
That's what a agreeable person would do.
A disagreeable person would be more
successful with regards to competition.
A person who's high in neuroticism would
be,
would be tried to protect themselves and
to establish some sort of security and
open person would be looking for a
flexible creative environment.
And so there's this multiplicity of,
of ways that you can establish a
dominance hierarchy and be successful in
it.
And if you're creative,
you can come up with your own damn
dominance hierarchy,
which is exactly what you're doing.
If you're creative,
right?
You,
you spin up a game that's your game and
then you,
you make the rules.
And that's hard because if you make a
new game with new rule,
if it's hard to monetize it,
but you can be the best at playing that
game.
And so that's a huge advantage to being
creative if you can pull it off.
So then you think,
well,
what's happened among human beings is
the multiplication of the set of
possible dominance hierarchies.
So it's become very broad.
And then you could say,
well,
what's,
what's driving selection now is the
ability to be successful across multiple
sets of dominance,
hierarchies.
And that accounts,
at least in part for our cognitive
flexibility.
And so that's really what a human being
is.
A human being is a creature that has
high potential for succeeding across a
very wide range of potential human
dominance hierarchies.
And so that gives us our transformative
psyche.
That's the niche that,
that's the niche that we've both
produced and occupy.
And I think it's out of that,
that hero mythology emerges
fundamentally because I think what the
hero is,
the mythological hero is a
representation of that part of the
psyche that's particularly good at being
successful across sets of dominance
hierarchies.
It's a very,
very biological way of thinking about
it.
And I thought about this for a long
time.
I can't see any way that that just can't
be the case.
And how else,
how else could it work if we had a fixed
behavioral pattern like beavers,
you know you're the most successful
beaver.
If you build the best damn,
it's like fine.
Then you know what's going to be
selected for it.
But that isn't what people are like and
it's also why we're so multipurpose.
You know we have hands.
What's a hand for?
What's the evolutionary of a hand?
Well you,
you can't specify that.
You could say it's something like,
well the hand is useful for doing a
whole bunch of different things with
well and mouth.
Tongue,
same thing.
What are words for while it's the same
thing,
therefore very there for communicating a
very wide range of information.
It's something like that.
So were were these weird general purpose
animals,
you know,
we're not great at any one thing,
but we can swim better than most
terrestrial animals.
You know,
we can run faster than most animals and
we could certainly run longer.
Like a human being can run a horse to
death over the course of a week if
they're in good shape.
So like,
we're really good at being multipurpose
entity,
like a rat,
you know,
were they call rats,
weedy species because they can be
anywhere.
They don't have a specific niche.
Like,
you know,
there's animals down in,
in,
uh,
the Amazon that are specialized for like
one tree,
you know,
or one type of tree in one tiny little
area.
That's not what human beings like is,
were we're like,
cockroaches are rats,
which is nasty comparison,
but we can go anywhere and thrive.
And so,
and so being particularly good at that,
being particularly good at being able to
go anywhere and thrive also seems to me
to be a canonical element of the hero
mythology.
So,
so,
okay.
All right.
Now.